mots étaient brotherson merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
pour commencer
pourquoi la question des indemnisations
des victimes d'essais nucléaires fait
partie du projet de loi lié à la crise
sanitaire du coc vide 19
on a du mal à faire le lien comment at
il été justifiée par le parlement alors
écoutez moi aussi j'ai du mal à faire le
lien je ne vois pas où est la logique
autant faire une loi sur la banane et
légiférer sur les bateaux de course ça
ça n'a absolument rien à voir
et il n'y avait pas d'urgence à planche
ces modifications
donc nous ne comprenons pas non plus que
ce soient les députés ou les
associations les victimes n alors
qu'elle a été la vôtre réaction et celle
des polynésiens particulièrement des
victimes après l'adoption définitive de
ce texte je peux vous dire le tissier en
polynésie l'indignation et le sentiment
général
un sentiment de mépris de la part de
l'état un sentiment de non respect de la
douleur qui est celle d'être amis des
victimes qui souffrent encore ils ont
perdu des êtres chers
et puis par rapport à mon cas à ce fait
colonial ceci nucléaire alors sur les
réseaux sociaux particulièrement sur
facebook vous aviez publié une vidéo
dans laquelle vous dénonciez un déjà ce
texte est la décision des députés avant
que le sénat ne le supprime
vous évoquiez alors un cavalier
législatif pourquoi qu'est ce que vous
entendez par là c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé le quart et les législatives
concerne consiste à dans un texte qu'il
n'a rien à voir avec le sujet à
introduire donc des amendements qui
viennent modifier le sujet la première
modification a utilisé la même technique
puisque c'est dans le cadre de la loi de
finances je crois que c'était
l'amendement 1800 sur plus de 2700
amendements dans quelque chose que
personne n'a vu passer glisse
voilà une modification de la loi qui
permet de modifier qu'à tout autre sujet
et c'est exactement ce qui a été fait à
nouveau ici puisque c'est dans la loi
sur le produit
un projet de loi sur le co vie de
chaussures lakovic 19 cas été inséré
donc un amendement dont le nom rétablir
avec rétroactivité de cette contrainte
du millisievert
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
volonté du gouvernement
encore une fois j'ai du mal à comprendre
parce que content quand on fait le ratio
entre ce que ça représente de
budgétairement cesser ce n'est pas grand
chose pour la france pour la république
et de l'autre côté le sentiment de
mépris qu'occasionne donc ces
modifications le politiquement je ne
comprends pas où est la logique du
président la république puisque c'est un
c'est venu du gouvernement lancé à un
moment donné ça ils accordent les ans la
république je ne le comprend d'autant
moins qu'il avait prévu de venir en
polynésie faire une grande tournée en
avril vance a été décalée à cause de 19
mais je suppose qu'il va vouloir
remettre ça une fois que tout ça va
devenue un peu normal je peux vous dire
qui sera moyennement ati ici encore très
concrètement à quelles sont les
conséquences pour les pour les victimes
que l'on comprenne bien après l'adoption
de ce texte
en fait après l'adoption de ce texte il
ya une rétroactivité d'un amendement qui
est et plis fin 2018 et qui impose donc
une limite
vous savez autres avant cela que lui
avait il y avait deux critères il avait
le critère de date il va il fallait
avoir séjourné dans contre l'isi dans
dans un certain laps de temps qui
correspondait aux essais nucléaires et
le deuxième petit air c'était d'être
atteint d'une des maladies
radio-induites listées dans la langue ce
cette modification vient introduire la
nécessité de trouver qu'on a été exposée
à plus de un millisieverts ce qui dans
bien des cas pour les patients qui ne
disposent pas de leurs dossiers médicaux
puisque c'était classé top secret et
relève
une formalité impossible alors pour
conclure vous n'étiez pas présent à
l'assemblée nationale lorsque la mesure
est passée la première fois toujours
dans votre vidéo vous dites qu'ils ont
attendu qu'il n'y ait aucun
parlementaire polynésiens présent pour
examiner le texte
vous pensez que c'était vraiment
volontaire de le faire en votre absence
je pense malheureusement que c'était
effectivement volontaires puisqu'il n'y
avait aucun de mes collègues députés de
mes collègues députés sont de deux
femmes les deux sénateurs n'était pas là
non plus et il aurait très bien pu
programmer le passage ce texte avant que
nous revenions non puisque nous étions
tous en métropole après que le texte
soit passé au sénat
en général ça peut être transmis à
l'assemblée nationale dans un délai très
court
ils n'ont pas fait ils ont attendu très
précisément que nous soyons tous partis
pour faire passer ce cavalier législatif
merci beaucoup mais était brotherson
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes député gdr de la
troisième circonscription de la
polynésie française